welcome to the newshour former pakistani
prime minister imran khan is facing
terrorism charges after being accused of
making threats against the police and
judiciary at a political rally
supporters have gathered outside his
home in the capital islamabad warning of
mass protests if he's arrested the high
court has granted khan protective bail
until thursday now he lost a
no-confidence vote back in april but in
a struggling economy his popularity has
surged his latest rallies have drawn
tens of thousands of people kamal haider
is outside imran khan's residence in
islamabad with more on the charges
imran khan's party leaders and
supporters have gathered
outside his residence in banigala
which is situated on a hilltop
now earlier there were reports that
imran khan would be arrested
however his lawyers then went into the
islamabad high court from where they
were able to get a bail before arrest
and therefore giving some relief to the
former prime minister there was tension
here the supporters saying that they
will not leave this place nor will they
allow anyone to arrest their leader and
the party had warned that they would
then have
a country-wide protest bringing life to
a virtual standstill given the fact that
imran khan's party enjoys support in two
key provinces also in
gilgal baltistan and also in pakistani
administered kashmir people of pakistan
have decided then they need a revolution
in this country and it will come
and the destination nation is not that
far now it is the public reaction
because
no no military no uh agencies no police
no paramilitary forces no one can stand
against the people of our country we are
the strength of our forces now it will
be important to see whether imran khan
will be arrested when he appears before
the anti-terrorist court on the 25th but
this definitely gives him more time
and also to be able to work out a
reaction now his party leaders have been
coming
from across the country to his residence
and of course they will be mulling over
plans on how to move forward
ibrahim is an advocate at the supreme
court of pakistan and a former
additional attorney general and joins me
now live from karachi good to have you
with us sir on the program now the
authorities cite that comments made
against the police and a magistrate
constitute a terror threat what do you
make of that
well i think the threats made by the
former prime minister at a political
rally uh although charged and incendiary
they don't constitute terrorism and the
supreme court of pakistan has earlier
interpreted pakistan's terrorist laws as
saying that these cannot be interpreted
for a persecuting political speech it
does seem that politicians in pakistan
go through this ritual of arrest
imprisonment house arrest or detainment
it's like a right of passage if you want
to enter pakistani politics are we
seeing anything different here
uh no not at all in fact it is the very
same script uh former prime ministers
benazir bhutto and navajri also went
through a similar
episodes of being charged for terrorism
or even treason and after that it was
basically good standing to get back into
office we've got to understand until a
few months ago imran khan was being
you know they were being criticized and
taunted for being a selected prime
minister selected by the establishment
and now he is a renegade rebel leader uh
who is really has galvanized the masses
in his support indeed i mean the
pictures that we're seeing are of
hundreds of thousands of people you know
waving flags and supporting him so there
seems to be this legal battle going on
now about whether he can be arrested or
whether he
can preempt arrest with this bail order
for the at least another few days it's
all getting very messy legally so seeing
those pictures of all the public so very
happy or a large majority of them do
they have the stomach for a long
drawn-out political argument in the
current economic climate that pakistan
is facing right now
well i think that is a very good
question because pakistan simply cannot
afford a political wrangling of this
size which will have a former prime
minister charged for terrorism uh
certainly his supporters won't take it
down very well and the courts will have
to come together and they have already
they've given him a protective bill and
i personally don't see any chances of
even the government trying to arrest him
but also from their perspective they had
no
opportunity to
sit back and take the uh threats that
the former prime minister had levelled
the current prime minister shabaz sharif
has quite a few problems on his hands
the economy being one of them but huge
climate change problems in the south of
the country in the sindh and balochistan
province where there was torrential rain
and a great deal of flooding affecting
millions of people down there is he
taking the eye off the ball or is the
government taking their eye off the ball
by focusing too much on khan
uh yes indeed and in fact it is being
criticized for exactly that
and the mainstream media is being
criticized that the
real agony and suffering that the people
of pakistan have been facing especially
in provinces of balochistan and south
punjab has been ignored at the cost of
this drama in politics
and of course imran continues to be a
popular in certain quarters of the
country certainly in the north in in
several provinces
do you think or how do you think this is
going to play out in the next few days
or certainly in the next few weeks
because
there is talk about the general election
being brought forward uh by at least one
year to october is that too much of a a
possibility
i think that is a possibility given the
fact that uh the current uh coalition
government recently lost their majority
in the most populous punjab province now
that is under control of mr imran khan's
uh coalition partners now if uh imran
khan
wants an election at the national level
he'll have to dissolve his gov his own
government in uh two provinces and i
don't think he has the stomach to do
that right now
certainly interesting times for pakistan
we'll of course keep a very close eye on
what's happening ibrahim joining us from
karachi thank you
thank you